hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about something that I think is
important and that is that in language
learning I believe that the process the
process of learning is the goal rather
than the ultimate achievement or
whatever we're able to do in the
language in other words if we can enjoy
the process remain active commit
ourselves to the process that that is in
itself the goal if we enjoy the process
of run enough time into the process the
achievements will take care of
themselves and the reason I talk about
that is oh and I should point out that
at link our statistics basically cover
the activity level how many words you've
read how many hours you listen how many
words and phrases you've saved to your
database why because these are things
that you can control you can't
necessarily control the outcome some
days you may do better or you may feel
that you did better and some days you
may feel that you did worse but if you
are putting that effort if you are
reading listening saving words and
especially if you are enjoying it the
outcome will be good it can only result
in better performance in the language
but I don't think it's worthwhile
worrying about your performance so the
focus should be on making sure that you
maintain a sufficient level of activity
and that you enjoy that activity the
results will take you know look after
themselves and so I mentioned that
because you know and I go to speak in
German by the way after explaining these
things in English today as I did in
Russian the other day and undoubtedly I
will make mistakes and people will point
these mistakes out which is fine and I
appreciate that however you know how
much more effort should I put into
worrying about my performance and maybe
spending a couple of days brushing up my
Russian or brushing up my
in order to perform maybe a little bit
better because I'm concerned about my
performance if I enjoy doing that that's
fine but right now I'm focused on my
Arabic and so I want to stay with my
hair of it so the point I want to make
is that sometimes you know you can never
be perfect so you can always say well I
don't want to talk because I haven't
quite you know achieved the level that I
need to be now I often say that I don't
like to talk from the beginning but once
I start talking it's it's not the
concern that I won't do well that holds
me back from speaking I generally say if
I reach 3,000 words or a certain level
of vocabulary in a language now I feel I
can understand what people are saying no
I feel I have some words I'm gonna go
for it I'm gonna make mistakes I don't
care but I have put all my emphasis on
the process of listening and reading to
bring myself up to a level where I now
can start to engage with people in the
language so the process is the goal and
I'm reminded of the myth of sisyphus an
old Greek myth where this old man was
pushing a rock up the hill and the rock
kept on rolling back down and he pushed
it up and it kept on rolling back down
and to some extent in language learning
well you know if we leave our language a
little water we might get a little bit
rusty and then we push it back up the
hill again I mean I think we get better
and better unlike old Sisyphus but just
as I'll give a become who said in his
essay about the myth of Sisyphus while
this activity might seem absurd to push
a rock up a hill and see it roll down
again probably the man pushing the rock
up the hill is enjoying the process so
and just similarly in our lives which in
a way this myth of Sisyphus is sort of a
parable which illustrates the absurdity
of life but as pemuda concludes it's not
observed absurd if the man
she enjoys pushing the rock up the hill
and having it roll down and then pushing
it up the hill again so the myth is the
yeah a little bit the process is the
goal that's the method message for today
and I'm going to try to say that a
German although I haven't spoken German
for a long time now yes very specimen
does about Deutsch design in which Park
11 that puts us yeah does what says is
that see okay but this is their shredder
also delights to justice did much my
best about polymer this is a vector
control iam about the process with
inside the image to the diamond is a
sparkled and thus can man continum or
does waiting on vermin facade on Wendy
hot see is Nikolay stone about this
superb process as often demolished to
home to let loose pregnant on Daniel
darn fast to hub main man also does
marked done via till I stone Zeb's also
in mbatha-raw is on just waiting to buy
spill in link edit link cotton Solomon
done via confidence a statistic v tilde
has to hurt Roberta has to be less we
feel the Bur Toronto's etc how saga has
to expire cut on the city DD activity
the safety lies to a bar to work this
activity done via the light stone EEMA
better okay oh Emily me to make out with
Angus
we have to have any kill each other yes
predatory Charizard I mean destroy trees
form a habit avenues result these are my
notes to even days
but it's better service affair one
minute unsub that does mine and I start
slacking dish is mostly done ahaha
best design so he's already failed my
hot sake yet is what does process yes
let him learn a garbage on does this for
me don't have this passage better is
melted a rubbish lemon or the bashful
offended somebody spin ow
also afflict the icy mill say a rubbish
on a moon reporter on a mover
oh yeah well done the plane give a clear
enough toys ha
finish is to share these other garbage
truck Timbuktu layer to layer on the
swing
the guns text by Hubbard e the audio not
done how this does the concept book
transphobia lassen undone
abided is a gel the text of link
analysis there like on escape contrition
and dispossessed mark pass on vanish
past mark does Verde Verde Shima basa
won't be in the in the English target
Arcada
the sis VD limit Francisco's
this was one man doctor it's time to
talk nah nah home who does hold order
would mi gente and fear other Camilla's
far and symbol Zachman the this absurd
kaitlin's Allah communicates act me
Muhsin out loud that this man Joseph is
a hot basket and these are signs who
Hagen hunter
oh no not normal NACO
this can be exactly on the laden own
search party learnin about Hagen Ellen
sue Guinta the event
EEMA Edition her new arrival mascaras
are but when the possum in the process
with Las Vegas is the spot says Vista
and Oda does process is that seal okay
Tiger won't I'll be the same now
[Music]